a brief farewell before the late rest
it's thought there are thousands more
dead under the rubble in dharna the
Eastern Libyan City that's suffering
with its deadliest disaster
ten days after the September 10 storm
destroyed the city's two dams rescue
efforts continue
in exceptional cases survivors are found
but hopes are fading of finding any more
alive
in Libya's situation it's not an
earthquake but a flood meaning adrift
with the destruction of homes it's very
difficult to find survivors in such
conditions especially in muddy areas not
to mention those who have swept into the
sea as you know there's no survival when
you're in the water for more than a few
minutes
recovering bodies from the Seas and
other challenge entire families were
swept to the Mediterranean
summoned their cause and there is a need
for specialized equipment to extract
them adding to the complications are the
political divisions in the country Libya
has two rival governments one in the
East that's appointed by the Parliament
and another here and Tripoli that's
recognized by the International
Community the prime minister of
tripoli's national Unity government
Abdul Hamid Baba has been touring Aid
centers in the capital to mobilize
efforts but without reaching out to his
rivals in the East it will be difficult
to see a smooth flow of Aid people's
grief is now turning into anger
people in Ghana are calling for
accountability they held the government
in the East and its main backer
Parliament speaker
responsible for their Agony
this is not you Aquila Saleh who says
that we will rebuild derna in six months
you are a killer how will you rebuild
derna derna God willing will be built
with its Martyrs who are still in the
water until now many believe if there
weren't political divisions this tragedy
could have been avoided and with
pictures of the protest circulating on
media many foreign journals that were
allowed into the city said they'd been
ordered out a claim that was denied by
the Eastern government Tripoli